si chers collègues l'ordre du jour
appelle la question orale numéro 536 de
madame catherine de roche à madame la
ministre des affaires sociales et de la
santé
la parole est à notre collègue catherine
de roche auteur la question merci madame
la présidente madame la ministre je
souhaitais vous interroger sur les
conditions d'accès aux indemnités
journalières qui avec l'évolution du
marché du travail sont devenues
inadaptées discriminante pour certains
salariés travaillant moins d'habitants
en effet l'article r 313-3 du code de la
sécurité sociale conditionne le
versement des indemnités journalières en
cas d'incapacité temporaire pour maladie
soit une durée minimum d'activité
professionnelle sur une période de
référence précédant l'arrêt soit une
cotisation sur un salaire minimum au
cours de cette même période
ainsi pour un arrêt inférieure à six
mois la durée minimum de travail salarié
est 200 heures effectuées au cours des
trois derniers mois pour un arrêt
supérieur à six mois la durée minimum de
travail salarié de 800 heures effectuées
sur l'année précédente dont au moins 200
heures au cours du premier trimestre or
ces deux conditions exclut une partie
des salariés notamment ceux travaillant
à temps partiel
ainsi les salariés dans l'intérêt du
travail inférieure à huit en sont
exclues des droits pour lesquels ils
cotisent cependant en effet ces salariés
cotisent à fonds perdus sans pouvoir
prétendre à un quelconque revenu de
remplacement
lorsque la maladie les empêche de
travailler ainsi selon la cour des
comptes 20 à 30% de la population
salariée ne seraient pas couvertes la
ligue contre le cancer a attiré mon
attention sur cette discrimination
elle chiffre à 15 mille le nombre de
personnes atteintes du cancer concernés
par cette absence de revenus de
remplacement
sur ses quinze mille personnes malades
treize mille femmes travaillent à temps
partiel
un temps inférieures à un mi temps ces
salariés se retrouvent sans aucun revenu
aggravant ainsi une situation précarisés
par la maladie les personnes atteintes
d'un cancer n'ont souvent pas d'autre
alternative que de s'arrêter
professionnellement pour suivre des
traitements généralement longs
de surcroît ces personnes doivent
supporter des dépenses de santé non
remboursés malgré l'accord national
interprofessionnel janvier qui s'est
traduit dans la loi du mois de juin
qui fixe à 24 heures par semaine le
temps partiel minimum des dérogations
seront possibles et notamment pour
raisons personnelles et les problèmes de
santé seront vraisemblablement au coeur
de ces dérogations
le problème demeurera donc madame la
ministre
question est la suivante quelles mesures
comptez vous prendre pour qu'un revenu
remplacement un revenu de remplacement
puisse être accordée en contrepartie des
cotisations versées à ses salariés merci
cher collègue madame la ministre vous
avez la parole madame la présidente
merci madame la sénatrice catherine de
roche je vous prie de m'excuser marisol
touraine que je remplace et je fais la
réponse à sa place aujourd'hui pour les
droits aux indemnités journalières de
l'assurance maladie
l'assuré doit justifier d'un montant de
cotisation ou d'une durée minimale
d'activité au cours d'une période de
référence donnée et d'ailleurs comme
vous venez précisément de le dire pour
les arrêts de travail de moins de 6 mois
la durée minimale d'activité et de 200
heures d'activité au cours des trois
derniers mois soit 15 heures par semaine
pour les arrêts de travail de plus de 6
mois elle est de 800 heures au cours des
12 derniers mois dont 200 heures au
cours du premier trimestre les analytes
et journalières sont un droit constitue
un permet le versement de prestations
pour une durée d'au moins six mois et
pouvant atteindre trois ans dans ce
contexte le principe d'une durée
minimale de travail pour obtenir
l'ouverture des droits n'apparaît pas
illégitime
plusieurs évolutions ont d'ores et déjà
sont déjà intervenus qui tiennent compte
des difficultés rencontrées en
particulier par les salariés précaires
ou les temps très partiel ainsi pour les
salariés exerçant une profession à
caractère saisonnier ou à caractère
discontinue ainsi que pour les personnes
rémunérées par chèque emploi service
universel les conditions sont examinés
sur une période de 12 mois
en outre en cas de changement de régime
d'affiliation les périodes travaillées
dans le cadre d'un autre régime sont
également prises en compte
enfin le plfss pour 2013 a permis
d'améliorer les droits des chômeurs non
indemnisés end à miser qui reprennent un
emploi
un maintien du droit de trois mois leur
est désormais garanti lors
de la reprise d'un emploi afin de
pouvoir à nouveau remplir des conditions
d'activité toutefois madame la sénatrice
la question d'une nouvelle adaptation de
ces règles se pose aujourd'hui face à la
précarisation du marché du travail
et d'après les données de l'enquète
emploi en continu de l'insee en 2011 on
estime environ 3 % la part de la
population salariée ne remplissant pas
la condition des 200 heures de travail
sur le trimestre vous en faisiez
d'ailleurs et à cette question se pose
notamment pour les arrêts de longue
durée pour lesquels le cumul des règles
prive de droit les salariés qui
remplissent la règle des 800 heures
travaillées sur l'année un décret donc
ne conservant plus que les conditions
des 800 eur est en préparation en vue de
s'appliquer dès l'année prochaine dès
2014 et au delà de ça sachez qu'un
rapport a été demandé par l'assemblée
nationale dans le cadre du plfss pour
2014 qui permettra d'approfondir
justement plus que nous ne le faisons
ici dans ce débat rapide
l'évaluation est d'éclairer l'ensemble
du parlement sur ce sujet sensible pour
l'ensemble des salariés
merci madame la sénatrice merci madame
la ministre mme desroches souhaitez vous
répondre même le ministre très
rapidement même si madame la ministre en
effet je pense que c'est un sujet majeur
comme vous l'avait dit il ya une
précarisation du travail et nous avons
été alertés les parlementaires en effet
sur les difficultés notamment en cas de
maladies que peuvent que peuvent
percevoir certains salariés lorsqu'ils
se retrouvent démunis sur le plan
financier
au-delà des difficultés qu'ils
rencontrent sur le plan des soins et sur
le plan physique donc merci de ces
explications j'espère qu'elles prendront
forme rapidement pour résoudre ce
problème
merci chaque collègue l'ordre du jour
appelle la question orale numéro 573 de
monsieur michel bécot à madame la
ministre des affaires sociales et de la
santé
vous avez la parole me reconnais merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de la santé
l'ensemble des acteurs du nord de celle
en charge du projet de restructuration
du centre hospitalier nord de sève
satan dès le 16 juillet dernier à ce
qu'enfin l'état donne son feu vert à
cette opération initiée en 1996 suite à
la fusion des trois hôpitaux de
bressuire et parthenay et war il en a
pas été ainsi puisque la décision a une
nouvelle fois été repoussée en
complément d'information et de nouvelles
expertises ont été demandées
l'inquiétude dans le nord de sève et
grande madame la ministre
et cette non décision est difficilement
compréhensible par nos concitoyens
madame la ministre je vous remercie de
bien vouloir me préciser si oui ou non
les habitants du nord de sève peuvent
continuer à espérer
et enfin voir ce projet aboutir fin
décembre 2013
je vous remercie madame bonamie liste
des éléments qu'il vous sera possible de
me communiquer merci chers collègues la
parole et à madame la ministre
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur michel bécot là aussi je vous
réponds en lieu et place de marisol
touraine
comme vous le savez monsieur le sénateur
dès sa prise de fonction justement la
ministre des affaires sociales et de la
santé a pris connaissance de l'état
d'avancement du projet de
restructuration du centre auspices
hospitalier nord deux sèvres dont elle
sait qu'il est particulièrement attendu
non seulement de vous mais de la
population et qui est très soutenu par
les collectivités territoriales de la
région poitou charentes
vous l'avez d'ailleurs déjà interrogé
sur ce sujet en octobre 2012
la ministre a souhaité que le projet de
restructuration soit instruit assez
rapidement sur l'égide du comité de la
performance et de la modernisation de
l'offre de soins l'aco permet aux
puisqu'on aime bien les abréviations
qu'elle a installé en décembre 2012
le cope remet au pardon a déclaré le
projet éligible en avril 2013
il a formulé plusieurs recommandations
techniques en vue d'un examen pour une
décision complètement définitive et
finale pour répondre à ces attentes
l'établissement et l' agence régionale
de santé travaillent actuellement à la
finalisation de ce dossier
afin de garantir que le projet médical
qui sous-tend cet investissement soit
conforme au référentiel les plus
exigeants qu'ils soient il est notamment
attendu de l'établissement qui
s'engagent résolument sur le
développement des prises en charge
ambulatoire et qu'ils organisent le
parcours des patients en lien avec
l'ensemble des acteurs de soins sur la
totalité du territoire
donc la ministre des affaires sociales
et de la santé et confiante sur la
capacité de l'établissement et de l'
agence régionale de santé pour répondre
à ses attentes en vue je pense d'un
examen final pas par le cop ermo qu'elle
souhaite relativement proche que je ne
peux pas vous fixé aujourd'hui mais le
calendrier me semble assez resserrée
si madame la ministre chers collègues
bien je voulais réagir
non madame la ministre simplement un mot
pour vous dire que nous comptons sur
vous et sur votre gouvernement pour
enfin faire sortir ce projet qui depuis
maintenant 1996 est dans les cartons
merci merci chers collègues l'ordre du
jour appelle la question orale numéro
513 de madame pattes